now from across the world ukrainian
americans living in las vegas are
watching as that terror unfolds joe
mohler joining us now on the strip with
what many of them are telling us tonight
joe
the ukrainian americans i spoke to say
they're trying to constantly stay in
contact with their family in ukraine
they can't believe their eyes watching
this all unfold now we've seen
demonstrations showing support for
ukraine around the world in several
cities around the world and even here in
the united states now one is planned
here for the las vegas strip tomorrow
glory to ukraine glory to heroes got us
with us from las vegas that lana bully
is praying for her family in ukraine
where my parents live in odessa we have
a village very close
the bomb shoot over there immediately 20
civilians die this is a photo of her in
ukraine just years ago she is in
constant contact with family and says
people there are putting up a fight we
are not running away we're showing the
world that this is our land now the las
vegas community is coming together to
show support for ukraine we
aren't going to serve russian products
evil pie in downtown las vegas is
dumping all russian vodka and replacing
it with ukrainian vodka a five dollar
shot special starts saturday money to
help the people of ukraine it's just a
way of sending a message that you know
we don't support what's going on right
now at ron's eastern european market in
the southwest valley these flyers popped
up a demonstration is planned on the las
vegas strip saturday they don't want to
give up their free country their free
city if kiev collapses ukraine the whole
ukraine collapses demonstrations have
been happening around the world that's
what we're asking to show our voice to
be hurt now local ukrainians want to
send a message anyone can show up
ukrainian russian-american we're all
fighting for peace and we want the world
to see us
back out here live that demonstration is
planned for this trip tomorrow at 3 p.m
nathalik reporting live joe mulder live
welcome